l'immense déception le dégoût même des
familles des 228 victimes du crash Rio
Paris 14 ans après leur disparition la
justice s'amusore de cause hier les
entreprises air français Airbus parmi
les quatre victimes Touran Élise et son
mari la tente de la jeune femme était
présente hier à Paris clair du Rousseau
n'a pas de mots assez dur contre la
justice les la Turquie et la rencontrer
très complice et très fusionnel à ma
prise dans ses bras puis ma sœur du coup
a pris une photo 14 ans après Airbus et
Air France sont relaxés des charges
d'homicides involontaire le tribunal
estime qu'il n'y a pas de lien de
causalité entre les fautes commises et
l'accident pourtant la lutte continue
pour les proches des victimes avec un
espoir le parquet général qui peut
encore faire appel
en continuera et on se battra alors
après je ne sais pas combien de temps
deux ans cinq ans je ne sais pas mais en
a combattu presque 14 ans donc on est
plus à deux ans près vous savez les deux
entreprises sont cependant reconnus
responsables civilement et devront donc
indemniser les familles des victimes le
tribunal juge que les dysfonctionnements
ont augmenté la probabilité que
l'accident arrive une nouvelle audience
est donc attendue le 4 septembre pour
l'évaluation des dommages et intérêts